In southwestern China,
engineers are putting
the finishing touches on
a grand astronomy facility:
A half-kilometer wide dish
nestled in themountains
that will gather radio
signals from the cosmos.
FAST -- set to be the world’s largest radio
telescope-
is modeled on the second
largest dish in the world,
the Arecibo Observatory
Started in 2011, the cost of
construction for the FAST facility
is estimated to be
$180 million dollars.
Spherical dishes reflect and
concentrate incoming waves
from a range of angles,
but not onto a single point,
delivering a distorted
image to receivers.
FAST is breaking new ground with a design
that pulls a section of the dish
into a gradually moving parabola
An array of actuators pull a 300-meter section
into a temporary shape --
this can be aimed at and track
cosmic objects as the Earth rotates
The receiver moves in concert
with the axis of the parabola
This brings the benefits of
a rotating, tilting antenna
to a dish that is firmly fixed in place.
Single dishes excel at
observing point sources
like neutron stars and
at scanning a multitude
of frequencies in the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
When it comes online, the world’s largest
radio telescope will also catalog pulsars,
as well as probe gravitational
waves, dark matter,
and a recently discovered
phenomenon called fast-radio bursts